what got you into wanting to do films
I like TV shows bro I like movies I've
always liked movies and TV shows and
stuff like that and um I like how
the directors
make us feel some type of way
you know like who's your favorite
director
or whoever did Game of Thrones oh yeah
yeah I mean Game of Thrones is great
besides season eight which was [ __ ]
atrocious exactly so but
him for example he make you hate
characters he make you love characters
yeah he makes you want to watch the next
episode immediately of course you know
what I'm saying so that was interesting
to me and I wanted to kind of do that as
well through music I like that and then
you know what else too is like
you got to really get in that bag and
start writing your show to tell that
Detroit story from like the snowfall
perspective because I know a couple
homies so that their life to the 90s
they just they're from the streets and
they've already gotten like real TV
deals because all these networks are
trying to do the next snowfall yeah
somebody gotta tell that Detroit story
that's a fact the white to them tap in
hey the wire told the Baltimore side you
ever watched The Wire I did that's my
favorite show ever I do
spot on stars are you trying to take 50
spot on Stars so it's exclusive
replacing 50 Cent coming right up if you
don't want that I'll Focus 50 Cent as
you should yeah
I'm gonna lie if stars and 50 hit me up
I'm going 50 Cent of course 50 is a one
I'm going 50 cents it's not the two yeah
facts but stars do need to you know I'm
saying feel that Gap because they left a
big gap when he left well all the shows
are gone yeah when he leaves it's like
what's next I don't know they had the
whole power Universe being black you
know obviously BMF yeah so you love Game
of Thrones
so you kind of wanted to apply
storytelling like a TV series to the
music side is it hard to pull that off
conceptually
because it's hard to pull that off on a
TV show it's not hard to pull it off for
me nah it's not nice
it's easy and um it's hard making a
regular song I was gonna say break down
like the chapters like somebody say make
a Club Banger right now right like the
[ __ ] I'm gonna go ahead and say
and then it might not work and you don't
even be in the club exactly but if you
tell me make a chapters of the trenches
all right bet I can't tell your story
exactly you could do that with no not no
pun intended with no effort exactly
exactly exactly see what I did there
yeah
um how much did you hate season 8 of
Game of Thrones did you hate it as much
as I did because it almost ruined the
whole series for me
I probably hated it more than everybody
it was so disappointing yeah bro because
I ain't wanted to end like that that
ain't the end that I wanted and then I
didn't want to end that quick like they
rushed so much yeah facts the fact that
all of them I feel like House of dragons
is rushed too though I only saw the
first episode I feel like it's Rush bro
like y'all skipping 10 years and [ __ ]
right now check this out what if I
wanted to see what happened through
those 10 years yeah I mean I think
that's what was great about the first
seven seasons of Game of Thrones it was
so slow and methodical and it built
characters so slowly and then season
eight all of a sudden Daenerys is a
[ __ ] bad she's bad she's killing
innocent people the fact that the
[ __ ] war with the white walkers
lasted that should have been a whole
season right and [ __ ] should
have really died like how you build up
this [ __ ] winner is coming the whole
show and then you blow the load so fast
it should have been they should have
been man that [ __ ] was the worst bro
that's the fact and I'm gonna tell you
right house of dragons
one episode
it's a little girl
that's the one I saw the first one now
look check this out not one episode is
she a little girl and she liked it right
yeah experiencing herself the very next
episode she was a grown lady it was a
different character she had three kids
like God damn Jesus yeah I didn't I
wasn't ready for another version of her
yeah I don't know I haven't I gotta I
have no opinion I just know that Game of
Thrones season eight is a [ __ ] black
eye of all TV history yeah okay it's one
of the best shows ever and they [ __ ]
it up did you watch Dahmer I didn't mean
it's pretty wild yeah sick [ __ ] that guy
I gotta go rewatch The Wire you have to
yeah when did you watch it how long ago
it'd been like five years so I rewatched
it for the first time since like 2010
during the pandemic like the first like
months of the pandemic Was it crazy oh
yeah it still was fire it's even more
fire like after everyone I was like [ __ ]
it's up there to me it's like that and
Breaking Bad is my two favorite shows
okay did you watch Breaking Bad I didn't
what I didn't see you breaking bad it's
about a [ __ ] teacher who sells maps
yeah because he has cancer and he has to
pay for his [ __ ] [ __ ] damn do he beat
the cancer well he had so he was broke
his [ __ ] house was upside down he's a
[ __ ] science teacher in high school
and he needed to make money so his
brother-in-law is a DEA agent and takes
him on a Ride Along
and he notices while they're raiding a
house one of his ex students sneaks out
of the top roof
and he says and he didn't snitch on him
he just ran off he didn't say nothing
right and then his brother-in-law was
like yeah we just uh we just took you
know like 1.2 million dollars worth of
meth out of that house and and then the
light went off oh I'm a chemist I teach
chemistry
I can make meth and he made the best
[ __ ] in town the best [ __ ] okay
crazy that's on fire did he beat the
cancer though yeah yeah I'm listen man
you just gotta watch it bro okay it's
fire okay and then him and the student
who he saw Escape they partner up
and gangster [ __ ] bro that's why yeah I
gotta check that out it's [ __ ] ill
and then they did a spin-off called
Better Call Saul that's crazy better
cause I saw that was good too yeah yeah
yeah Yellowstone is not on that level
though relax just chill Yellowstone is
solid but it's like it's like it's like
surface level good it's like it's both
of these on Netflix yeah okay yeah
Breaking Bad and Better Call Saul but
you gotta watch Breaking Bad first then
you gotta watch Better Call Saul okay
yeah yeah and then and then don't watch
Dahmer it's disturbing it's just like
[ __ ] up it's like yeah yeah some
Milwaukee [ __ ] I don't know what they're
doing in the midwest over there but
y'all serial killers hit different over
there damn that was Milwaukee yeah now
every city in the midwest is super
different though too this is true very
diverse like weird super area like a
bunch of Swing States
it's super different bro it's crazy
white people are different in Detroit I
went to a tech N9 concert while I was
there for that week that white trash in
Detroit man I get it now hmm
like how's the white trash out here just
this is not Detroit white trash so when
I was sitting in there
I just the whole Eminem [ __ ] all
connected I was like yeah I said look at
these white people I get it I see it
yeah yeah a bunch of M M's if he never
would have popped off in this
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah white
dudes with dirty [ __ ] jinko jeans
wife beaters and Detroit tattoos on
their neck yeah yeah just living a lot
of that going around